[Música]
vamos a aprender a hacer reanimación
cardiopulmonar pero necesito ayuda aquí
1 y software segundo soy yo necesito
otro para cerristas por ahí
ya real walkie ayudante
[Aplausos]
voy a necesitar que circules hasta el
centro del redondel rojo y te desplomes
con una muerte súbita sin lastimarte por
favor vos podés
un aplauso por favor
cherry cherry estás bien cherry cherry
no me contesta y tampoco está respirando
por favor llama al 107 y pedí una
ambulancia tan rápido por favor 107
bueno como todos saben ayer y no le pasó
nada
para no lastimarlo vamos a continuar con
la práctica en un muñeco y le vamos a
dar un aplauso a jerry por esta gran
caída que tuvo
yo voy a hacer las compresiones
cardíacas para mantener la circulación y
te voy a pedir diego sí que sí en este
lugar hay algún desfibrilador vos me lo
pueda traer por favor en el trato hay un
montón pero ya te traigo uno
gracias
vamos a prender el desfibrilador
y vamos a hacer lo que el desfibrilador
nos indique
cuando nos diga rompemos los paquetes y
extraemos los electrodos
con electrones de plástico
en el e3 de plástico
no es de alta gente analizando el ritmo
7 que al paciente analizando el ritmo
se descarga
atardecer
explicaré
pero aplicada
en este caso puede pasar como lo hicimos
rápido que el abra los ojos y pregunte
obviamente qué fue lo que me pasó la
respuesta no es te moriste quédate
tranquilo
la respuesta es tranquilizarlo y ponerlo
siempre con los parches colocados en la
posición de rescate para que espere a la
ambulancia esto es lo que nosotros
tenemos que hacer ponerlo de costado
para que espere a la ambulancia
tranquilo
bien ahora mientras se le espera a la
ambulancia yo lo que les quiero contar
es que en la argentina hay una muerte
súbita cada 15 minutos
entonces nosotros
tenemos que pensar que cuando ocurre
esta muerte súbita ocurre de esta forma
en cualquier parte en personas que se
sentían bien
en personas que se sentían bien
que estaban previamente sanas y que
parecían no tener nada
es 200 veces más frecuente morirse
así del corazón que morirse en un
incendio piensen ustedes ahora la
cantidad de matafuegos que hay por todos
lados y sin embargo que pocos
desfibriladores que nosotros vemos
este tipo de muertes que son inesperadas
en la mayoría de los casos son
producidas por una arritmia esta
arritmia hace que el corazón que venía
latiendo normalmente deje de latir y
empiece a temblar
provocando la muerte el único
tratamiento posible es comenzar con las
compresiones cardíacas para mantener la
circulación y utilizar un desfibrilador
para que el corazón deje de temblar se
recete y vuelva a arrancar y al latir
con normalidad
si nosotros logramos hacer las
compresiones cardíacas y la utilización
del desfibrilador dentro de los primeros
tres minutos la posibilidad de que esa
víctima llegue con vida al hospital es
altísima es del 80% ahora sí nosotros no
hacemos nada casi ninguno va a llegar
vivo al hospital es por esto que tanto
las compresiones cardíacas como la
utilización del desfibrilador forman
parte de la cadena de la vida son los
dos eslabones centrales ahora esta
cadena de la vida que tiene cuatro pasos
tiene tres pasos que están afuera del
hospital que son ustedes los que los van
a activar porque nadie sale con un
médico en el bolsillo por si le pasa
algo si te pasa algo el que te reanima y
el que te ayuda es el que tienes al lado
y es por eso que el primer eslabón es
pedir ayuda al 107 si ustedes ven que
alguien que estaba normal
se cae ustedes lo llaman y no no
contesta y tampoco respira es una
situación grave hay que llamar a la
ambulancia al 107 o el número de
emergencias local inmediatamente tenemos
que comenzar con las compresiones
cardíacas que se hacen en el centro del
tórax en el centro del pecho rápidas
fuertes y sin miedo para que sean
efectivas hay que comprimir el tórax y
hundirlo casi 5 centímetros para que la
circulación pueda funcionar ese es el
segundo paso el tercer paso es pedir un
desfibrilador acá en el colon hay si me
lo traen lo uso y sigo las indicaciones
del desfibrilador que habla en español y
me dice lo que yo tengo que hacer y
jamás va a disparar si esta persona no
tenía esa arritmia que provoca el
temblor del corazón por lo tanto nos
quedamos tranquilos porque no va a
funcionar si esa víctima no tiene una
muerte súbita
ahora si estamos en un lugar donde no
hay un desfibrilador
lo que hacemos es continuar con las
compresiones cardíacas hasta que llegue
la ambulancia que es el cuarto paso pero
la ambulancia va a llegar solo en tanto
y en cuanto en el primer paso la hayan
llamado por eso es muy importante llamar
primero a la ambulancia esto es de
tantísima importancia que hoy lo vamos a
practicar todos juntos acá entonces les
voy a pedir que ordenadamente todos se
pongan de pie por favor
vamos a sin golpear al de adelante a
estirar los brazos así bien estirados y
vamos a poner la mano hábil abajo y la
menos ávila arriba vamos a entrelazar
los dedos y vamos como a quebrar la
muñeca como a estirar bien los codos y
dejar la muñeca bien expuesta vamos a
bajar
y con los hombros le vamos a tirar el
peso del cuerpo sin doblar los codos
qué vamos a hacer ahora a ustedes les
dieron una bolsita cuando entraron
dentro de esa bolsa hay un corazón de
gomaespuma vamos a sacar ese corazón y
lo vamos a poner sobre el asiento
cuando todos estemos listos vamos a
practicar
la resucitación cardio-pulmonar con la
técnica de brazos y de manos que les
acabo de mostrar al ritmo de una canción
de los bee gees que nos va a marcar los
100 por minuto el ritmo lo va a marcar
una canción entonces si están todos
listos con sus corazones cuando yo digo
3 comprimimos a la una a las 2 y a las 3
[Música]
[Aplausos]
muy bien un aplauso para todos estos
reanimadores
ahora nos ordenamos nos volvemos a
sentar por favor que tengo dos cosas más
para decirles la primera los bee gees
nos regalaron este tema para que
nosotros podamos saber cuál es el ritmo
al que hay que hacerlo porque esta
música tiene el tempo a 100 por minuto
que es lo necesario para hacer las
compresiones correctamente quiere decir
que si en algún momento ustedes van a
hacer compresiones cardíacas pensando
esta canción lo van a poder hacer sea a
100 por minuto
piensa en la nada más no la canten queda
mal
la segunda recomendación es que ustedes
antes de hacer las compresiones
cardíacas tienen que haber sido testigos
tienen que haber visto que esa persona
se cayó inexplicablemente la tienen que
haber llamado que no conteste que no
respire haber llamado al 107 y recién
ahí comenzar con las compresiones no
salgan ahora con las manos así a
reanimar a todo lo que está en el piso
porque hay gente que también está
tomando sol
bueno apenas se gasta este círculo rojo
ves un montón de gente yo ahora me estoy
yendo y ya no veo más gente veo
reanimadores veo un montón de manos que
seguramente en algún momento van a
transformar una situación de muerte en
una situación de vida me voy feliz de
haber vivido esto con ustedes muchísimas
gracias a todos
[Música]